quand on regarde ce smartphone ce qui
est vraiment tout de suite hyper
intéressant c'est le fait qu'ils n'aient
[Musique]
je me suis posé une question vous avez
dit que vous en pensez et l'année
dernière sais pas si vous vous souvenez
au pot est arrivé en france avec une
énorme conférence sous la pyramide du
louvre là je fais la pyramide du louvre
je sais très belles chorégraphies et
justement au pot a présenté à ce
moment-là son nouveau fleuron son
nouveau flagship son smartphone qui fait
référence en tout cas chez au pot et qui
continuent pour l'instant à être une
vraie belle référence c'est le finepix
la question est est ce que un an après
le finepix vaut toujours le coup oui ou
non
alors justement j'ai ici un film x c'est
ce qu'on va regarder ensemble au delà du
côté un peu gadget de la caméra qui est
juste très sympa est-ce que ce
smartphone est encore un sens à ce que
ce smartphone est toujours d'actualité
est ce qu'il est intéressant par rapport
aux offres qu'on a sur le marché
actuellement alors vous savez qu'à une
très grosse concurrence à je vous
apprends absolument rien quand on
regarde ce smartphone ce qui est
vraiment tout de suite hyper intéressant
ces faits qui n'a absolument aucune en
poche il ya des points positifs il ya
des points négatifs et tout de suite
vous dire ce que j'en pense
il est sorti il ya un an et un an et
coûtait quelque chose comme mille euros
aujourd'hui il coûte moins cher on peut
le trouver à 799 euros d'ailleurs si
vous intéresse vous est bien le lien en
bas dans la description il ya des points
forts il a aussi des points faibles
laurent points forts d'agencés son
esthétisme et la définition qui sont
impeccables regardez ce qui est très
surprenant sur un smartphone c'est
d'avoir absolument aucun module caméra
apparent vous avez juste la marque ce
petit dégrader légèrement bleutée sur
les côtés le modèle qui notait la fine
dx design by au pot c'est vrai qu'il est
franchement super beau il est incurvé il
reste franchement très très beau très
minimaliste c'est un super beau design
qui a absolument rien qui bloque c'est
vraiment très très beau produit peut
être un peu glissant ça peut être le
côté un peu négatif de la côte est
quand on est sur un smartphone comme ça
c'est pas étonnant tu sois glissant il
faut mettre une coque de protection si
vous voulez pas qu'ils puissent
potentiellement en tout cas vous
échapper juste un bouton sur le côté
pour l'allumer pour l'état
ici les boutons de volume ou de
recharger ici en usb c'est votre tiroir
de double carte sim est ici sur ce
smartphone pas de carte microsd donc pas
de possibilité d'augmenter de côté vous
avez déjà beaucoup beaucoup de stockage
c'est un produit qui est beau qui est
minimaliste qui est sympa j'aime
beaucoup alors vous avez plusieurs
possibilités soit vous le déverrouiller
un peu classique fait un petit saut vers
le haut et il va s'allumer soit vous
utilisez la caméra qui est caché ici et
qui va avant l'espèce d'équivalent de
feuilles saïdi j'appuie je me mets en
face elle me voit et à sortir
directement c'est vrai qu'on s'est tout
de suite dit est ce que cette caméra va
tenir le coup est ce qu'elle va tenir
les 300000 cycle annoncé par la marque
ça dépendra toujours bien évidemment des
usages parce que dès lors que vous allez
utiliser qu'un petit grain de sable qui
peut rentrer dedans cas des poussières à
terme arrivera un moment où il y aura un
problème mécaniquement c'est obligatoire
dès qu'il se passe quelque chose
voilà il n'ya pas un système de
nettoyage qui a voulu signer mais c'est
vrai que la finition est vraiment
irréprochable
le détail a vraiment été soigné par la
marque et c'est vraiment très
impressionnant c'est vraiment chouette
alors à la différence de smartphones
comme le mime x32 xiaomi où c'est un
slider ou le pousser à la main tous et
vous leur ferme hélas pas du tout tout
se fait automatiquement c'est un peu un
smartphone pour les feignants ça des
verrous tout seul et ça s'est vraiment
bien et puis si vous regardez bien la
finition est juste coop
je dirais même pas que c'est un design
d'actualité je dirais que c'est un
design à part on le retrouve sur
quelques modèles vous ai dit notamment
sur le minix 3-2 xiaomi mais je trouve
vraiment beau vraiment bien réussit
surtout ici à la différence du mx3 vous
n'êtes absolument aucune caméra à
l'arrière et rien que pour ça c'est un
smartphone qui est vraiment unique
autre point très fort sur smartphone
c'est son grand écran oled de 6,4 pouces
de diagonale fhd plus c'est un écran qui
est très lumineux hop là regardez je
vous pousse à fond il est extrêmement
lumineux il est vraiment d'une très très
très belle qualité ce qui est vraiment
gêné avec cet écran c'est qu'il est
complètement immersif comme vous n'avez
absolument aucune encoches profiter
d'une expérience qui est vraiment bien
alors il faut venir zoom un peu sinon
vous avez vos barres sur les côtés mais
dans l'absolu pour regarder des vidéos
pour deux visions des sports du gaming
c'est vraiment un smartphone qui est
génial dans l'expérience multimédia vous
avez ici un seul haut parleur mono tissu
juste ici en bas ce qu'on pourra lui
reprocher c'est quand on tousse un peu
fort quand on pousse un peu le son il
devient assez imprécis
c'est pas la meilleure qualité audio
qu'on va retrouver sur un smartphone
néanmoins il ya beau
une puissance si vous êtes dans un
environnement qui est très bruyant et
vous avez pas peur d'en mettez tout le
monde vous pousser à fond il ya du son
on entend ça marche ça ses couleurs ou
côté multimédia c'est bien ce qu'on
pourra reprocher aussi c'est qu'ils
absolument pas de place pour mettre une
prise jack donc pas de prise jack si
vous l'écouté au casque il vous faudra
soit le petit casque usb c'est qu'ils
font directement dans la boîte soit
utiliser un casque bluetooth le dio
setec le point un petit peu au moyen de
ce smartphone parce qu'autant expérience
multimédia est vraiment génial avec ce
très grand écran par contre la qualité
est pas complètement folle derrière ça
c'est d'être un people le point de
revient total 1 points d'amélioration
que pourrait avoir oppose sur son
prochain modèle ci sort d'un autre
faille mixte peut être allez savoir
ça pourrait être vraiment cool en tout
cas si on peut comparer un an après même
s'ils sont pas complètement ouf on voit
que l'écran est juste magnifique
par rapport à ce qu'on a sur le marché
aujourd'hui des gouttes d'eau des bulles
des encoches là on a une proposition qui
est vachement intéressante qui est très
bien avec un écran y parvient calibre et
donc si vous voulez acheter un modèle de
2018 en 2019 avec une excellente qualité
le finepix franchement et topissime
maintenant via les finesses question des
performances parce que là on est sur un
soc de l'année dernière née sur un stand
ragone 845 alors si vous avez suivi en
décembre de qualcomm a sorti son
snapdragon 855 alors pour ceux qui sont
moins intéressés par le côté un peu spec
si vous y connaissez pas forcément en
processeurs pour smartphones il faut
savoir qu'on est dans les processeurs
les plus puissants c'est un dragon 845
ses modèles de l'année dernière les 855
ses modèles de cette année et là
effectivement elle dans des modèles de
l'année dernière bien évidemment le
smartphone est sorti l'année dernière ça
paraîtrait logique alors il ya une
différence entre le 855 qui équipe pas
mal de smartphones du marché et celui
845 on va retrouver une différence en
termes d'autonomie on va retrouver une
différence en termes d'intelligence
artificielle on va retrouver quelques
différences mais dans l'absolu le
qualcomm snapdragon 845 qui dans le
haut-pont phoenix est vraiment excellent
en plus vous avez 8 gigas de ram donc
vous avez un smartphone qui est hyper
fluide pour des sessions gaming pour
faire tout ce que vous voulez c'est un
smartphone qui est réactif qui est
rapide et même si honda le processeur de
l'année dernière pour moi ça fonctionne
parfaitement bien et d'ailleurs si vous
voyez la différence vous offre une boîte
de chocolat au piment d'espelette ou au
piment très fort comme ça vous ne
voudrez pas vous ne le réclame mais pas
pour tout vous dire il ya cent ans 24e
position
chez en tout où il est derrière galaxy
note 9
il est dernier
le réseau fon 2 de smartphones qui sont
très rapides donc là dessus on est aussi
sur un smartphone hyper rapide et un
smartphone qui reste vraiment
d'actualité en termes de performances
côté autonomie c'est pareil il reste
vraiment d'actualité on a une batterie
3400 méliand paire eur au delà des dans
le côté un peu technique et il faut
savoir que sur un usage standard on va
pouvoir regarder deux jours sans aucun
problème mais surtout le point fort ce
smartphone est là où il y en a pas
beaucoup qui lui arrive à la cheville
c'est la recharge rapide en une demi
heure vous la dire charger à 100% de 0 à
100% vous avez un bloc de recharge hyper
rapide vous branchez parle sa part
directement et ça c'est un atout
indiscutable
vous pouvez regarder sur le marché des
smartphones qui se rechargent aussi
rapidement voilà ça c'est une vraie bête
de compet ça c'est vraiment cool
entre poids qui fait ce smartphone
incontournable c'est la reconnaissance
faciale vous avez sensiblement
l'équivalent de fayçal dit ici vous
appuyez up élèves et déverrouille c'est
rapide ça je vous ai déjà montré mais il
le fait même dans le noir
bon là on est quasiment dans le noir
noir il ya juste un petit filet de
lumière derrière mais c'est impossible
de voir mon visage d'autant plus que je
suis à contre jour j'appuie ils
ouvrirent connais mon visage il y
verront tout de suite c'est vraiment
hyper impressionnant
on a donc toujours à faire un smartphone
qui est top en terme de technologie qui
est un bel écran qui va bien qu'ils se
déverrouille rapidement et je vous en
parlais tout à l'heure le côté photo
vidéo qui est intéressante puisque
l'appareil photo est caché ici seulement
dû à l'arrière et là sur le module de
l'avant alors vous avez ici un double
vodu photo l'arrière 16 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.0 et 20 mégapixels tu vois f
2.2 et à l'avant vous avez une caméra
telle fille de vingt-cinq mégapixels la
deuxième caméra l'ariane servira pour le
mode portrait ici pas de zoom optique
uniquement un zoom numérique x 2 soyons
très clairs le smartphone est bien
technologiquement il intéressant mais
par rapport à ce qui se fait cette année
en 2019
ça affecte le photophone le plus fou
vous allez si mauvais sur le pétrole pro
pour voir que le pétrole pro et au prix
auquel était le finepix quand il est
sorti on a un gars qui est énorme
c'est pas du tout la même chose à côté
de ça wine mais une grande gifle à tout
le monde en termes de photos même si
aujourd'hui il un peu moins cher en
photo ça va pas être le plus dingue
néanmoins il fait des clichés qui sont
quand même panade respectable vous
montre ça quelques photos qui sont pas
trop mal pour moi ce n'est pas un
smartphone qui est optimisé pour la
photographie le rendu photo par rapport
à lyon a trop peu trop à la concurrence
est pas exceptionnel j'ai essayé
différentes photos regarder en haut là
c'est un petit peu crâne et si l'on
regarde au niveau de ma fleur et
pourtant vous n'avez pas une
arnaud dingue c'est un sac ce smartphone
pour moi en 2019 est pas exceptionnel
par rapport à ce qu'on peut trouver à la
concurrence c'est probablement le point
faible de ce finepix également pour les
selles fils est pas le meilleur rendu au
delà que j'ai une vraie tête
d'enterrement ce matin et aidé certes
pas possible la qualité est pas
hallucinante nos modes portrait
fonctionne pas trop mal mais bon c'est
vrai que je suis pas transcendé par ce
smartphone dans l'absolu en termes de
photos j'ai un visage qui est
extrêmement lisse et on dirait que je
viens de gagner dix ans alors ça peut
être sympa
effectivement mais bon on est quand même
assez loin de la vérité à la question
est ce que le finepix reste un modèle de
référence en tout cas un excellent
smartphone en 2019 pour moi c'est un
excellent smartphone d'un point de vue
technologique parce qu'effectivement il
a un parti pris différents par rapport
aux autres d'un point de vue
technologique
le fait d'avoir ce déverrouillage en
infrarouge reconnaissance de visages ça
marche bien c'est aussi quelque chose
qui est très très bien le fait d'avoir
ce grand écran sans encoche pour moi ça
répond à beaucoup de problématiques
concernant le multimédia c'est vraiment
bien je trouve un peu faiblard au niveau
de l'audio niveau duo parlant je trouve
pas juger si vous l'écoutez comme ça je
pense qu'il vaut mieux utiliser un
casque bluetooth
là ça pourrait avoir un sens en termes
d'utilisation c'est un produit qui est
bien qui se recharge très rapidement si
de ce point de vue là il est vraiment
top maintenant du point de vue de la
photo je trouve assez moyens si vous
voulez un excellent photophone si vous
faites beaucoup de photos beaucoup de
partage sur les réseaux sociaux
pour moi c'est pas le finepix qu'il vous
faut je trouve intéressant pour beaucoup
de choses mais ça là les caméras pour
moi elle ne transforme pas à presque
s'arrêter c'est qu'il ait pas de
certification pour l'étanchéité et la
poussière
ça je pense que ça vient très clairement
du petit tiroir où effectivement c'est
un peu compliqué à certifier néanmois
c'est aussi compliqué s'il rencontre de
l'eau de façon accidentelle vous dire
mon smartphone a quasiment 1000 euros et
j'ai pas le garder ça peut être aussi un
point bloquant et autre point qui peut
être aussi en béton sur un smartphone
haut de gamme c'est le fait qu'il n'ait
pas de nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé notamment pour résumer
pour moi c'est un excellent smartphone
d'un point de vue technologique qui
ouvre la voie d'une certaine manière qui
fait référence dans son domaine qui
maintenant mais pas parfait ce
smartphone
il est fait pour vous si vous aimez
consulter du multimédia sera grand écran
et que vous écouter au casque si
maintenant à côté de ça vous êtes un
gros consommateur de photos fait
beaucoup de photos beaucoup partage sur
les réseaux sociaux pour moi c'est pas
forcément la suggérer
dites moi ce que vous en pensez est ce
que vous l'avez déjà acheté le finepix
comment vous le trouvez est-ce que selon
vous est toujours d'actualité en 2019
est ce que vous pourriez lâcheté oui
quoi comment vous marquez tout ça en
commentaire je vous invite à consulter
ma playlist qui passent par là vous
allez voir tous les smartphones du
moment
il ya plein de smartphones qui vont
arriver je vous en dis pas plus il ya
beaucoup de choses qui vont arriver dans
les jours dans les semaines à venir mais
ça va être hyper intéressante invite
donc à consulter la playlist est à vous
abonner
je vous embrasse vous dis à demain ciao